[Music]
a lot of times we have people here or
authors and thinkers and it's a rare
treat for me when we have someone that's
a that's a real doer and we've had a few
of these kind of Mastercraft spiel here
and I think there's in this case it's an
even rarer version of Master Craftsmen
who is who's both young as well as very
well studied in fields that that are
seem very esoteric in the world now but
Brittney Nicole Cox has a set of skills
that really nobody else in the world has
and is working on is working on kind of
machines that are similar in ways to the
the 10,000 year clock that I've been
working on and I've always been obsessed
with automata and she was able to kind
of craft an educational system to build
a way for her to do this in her life
which is a rarity in and of itself and
so I'm super excited to have her here
tonight welcome
well howdy um as you know my name is
Brittany Nicole Cox I am an antiquarian
neurologist
so I specialize in the conservation and
restoration of antique automata
mechanical music complicated clocks and
watches and mechanical magic it's really
amazing to be here at the long interval
because many things about this project
ring true to my personal values and the
things that I try to carry forward in my
work so I'm going to be sharing a bit
about my work with you and just to get
started this is a more complicated
example of what got me into this field
[Music]
it's pretty simple but you have this
incredible music that's just being
generated by basically these steel tines
that are tuned to a particular note that
are then being plucked in a sequence
that's been programmed to play you a
song when I was a kid I collected a lot
of these but my journey kind of started
a little bit earlier that's me and my
dad working on the car at least I
thought I was working on this car you
can see I haven't really changed much
I'm holding a screwdriver as time went
on though I kind of started to upgrade
my tools right so here this is a small
depth Ling tool so these come in various
sizes and when you work on a mechanism
you have to make sure that all of the
wheels and a gear train are poised and
they mesh perfectly together and these
come in a variety of sizes so you have
some for watches some for you know
carriage clocks were a little bit larger
and then some for even larger clocks
like long case clocks the tools get
quite complicated to work on the types
of objects that I work on you have to
have a large variety of these things and
they are just as beautiful as the
objects themselves and really just as
delicate so this is a balanced spring
scale that's on the left and what it
actually does is it measures tiny screws
that are part of the balance which
oscillates at a certain rate and so in
that little video played you could
actually see the balance rotating this
is a fusee engine so before we had
reliable spring steel you actually had a
fusee engine that was used to generate a
cone that basically would act as a
balance to the energy of an old spring
which was not reliable so basically as
you as you - bring up the power that it
can supply will change based on how it
unwinds and how that power is
distributed through the mechanism so you
had to have a specific tool to cut a
cone to match that power curve this is a
staking set each one of the stakes in
this tool are actually different and
used for a different purpose and it's
funny you you sometimes need multiple
sizes of all of these stakes just to do
one job and sometimes you'll never use
the same steak twice this is a wheel
topping tool
so this is for actually correcting worn
gear T if you can actually cut gears
with this as well if you have pre-cut
blanks so these are just to give you an
example of all the different tools a few
of the tools anyway that are necessary
to do the type of work that I do
you can obviously get a little carried
away so this is one gentleman shop it
was 5,000 square feet where he had
stockpiled this stuff over 30 years and
everything in here he used at one time
or another that's the other floor so
what are we using all this stuff for
really her ology right so when I said
I'm a her ologist this is really just
the study and measurement of time
historically units of time were defined
by movements of [ __ ] can you hear me
okay so son based the year was the time
that it took the earth to rotate around
the Sun the Moon the moon was based on
the moon's orbital period around the
Earth earth-based this was the time it
took for the earth to rotate on its own
axis celestial sphere base as in
sidereal time where the apparent
movement stars and constellations are
actually used to determine the length of
a year with all of this right and
different types of mechanical devices to
calculate time came opportunity so
mechanisms made to measure time could
also be used to create moving figures
possibly giving us some of the earliest
marriages between art and science this
is a page from the treatise on fantastic
devices invented by Muslim scholar
algae's re he was a mechanical engineer
artisan artist and mathematician this
elephant clock was especially intricate
every half hour the bird on the dome
whistled the man below would drop his
fall into the dragon's mouth and the
driver hit the elephant with his little
stick the met has this dated between
1000 and 1400 AD though some sources
dated at 1206
salzburg cathedral this is a pretty
common clock a lot of people know
don't know why that's playing okay great
this was said to be the oldest working
clock in the world other clocks 14th
century which in the chemical clock
first out Europe there were some in
Rouen as well as Paris Dijon and all of
these they've either been lost or
destroyed over time or substantially
modified so this is the oldest one that
we know of the wells cathedral clock
might have actually been made by the
same craftsmen as this particular clock
but is usually dated around 13 90 - this
is actually relocated in the Science
Museum in London it actually operates
there today this prague astronomical
clock may be the most well known a
Strama clock in the world the oldest
part of this clock is from 1410
although we do have records of clocks
preceding this piece besides a Chinese
astronomical from 1088 we have very few
clocks in Europe that actually date from
the mid 14th century wallingford was a
clock maker who actually did a lot of
different clocks and he had what was
considered a large astrolabe style clock
showing the Sun the moon's age phase a
node a star map and possibly the planets
an addition actually had a Wheel of
Fortune an indicator of the state of the
tide at London Bridge and bells that
rang every hour the number of Stokes
indicating the time these clocks
illustrate that one of the many impulses
and their development had actually been
the desire of astronomers to calculate
and investigate astral phenomena so I'm
basically taking you through a brief
history of these things I'm kind of
excited to get you some more what I feel
are the exceptional parts of her ology
but the history of watches began in 16th
century Europe so this is where
basically watches developed from a
portable spring driven clock which
appeared in the 15th century now this
was due to the invention of the
mainspring where I was shaving in that
tool earlier the susi generating machine
now that was actually created in order
to calibrate basically the springs
inside of these so here you have a fusee
you can actually see the fusee
let's see if you look there there's a
cone there at the bottom that's actually
what that tool that I showed you earlier
generates but in addition yeah about the
same time we actually have time finding
its way into the church or really rather
that church found its way into time we
have clocks that regulate prayer but we
also have these pieces that were
actually made to mechanize prayer so
this is a very interesting piece this is
a penitent monk this otamatone win wound
would actually glance left-to-right it
would open and close its mouth not its
head eye is gazing at the cross each
time and it moved about 20 inches
forward on a flat surface so this is
actually the act of mechanized prayer
this piece was I'm commissioned by King
Phillip when his son took a tumble down
some stairs and in an effort to convince
God to save his son he said God if you
grant me a miracle I will grant you one
in return and when his son healed he
commissioned the court clock maker to
actually create this penitent monk so
that he could go on running his kingdom
and have this pray piously for him
I mean can you imagine you're really
busy
you're a ruler you have a lot to do just
wine this guy up you good to go
this is actually quite a long clip
so her ology though was not just used
for prayer but actually also to frighten
churchgoers into penitence this is a
16th century devil otamatone that still
resides in the applied arts collection
and serve as a castle in Milan this was
actually a groaning bobbling demon so
when a churchgoer would enter the church
this this torso would be situated so
that you know someone hidden could
actually wind this crank which would
generate this horrible groaning sound
created by organ pipes and a waggling
demon head would pop up and scare you I
mean it went past making groaning demon
heads you actually had these mechanical
grottoes and heavens and hell's where
people would make pilgrimages to these
places to actually pay homage to these
things high an or pious you were the
more likely you got he were to see these
kinds of things one of these was known
as the Breton Jesus and it actually
would roll his eyes around in his head
he had blood flowing from a wound in his
side and there were women at his feet
you know just a chelating quite upset
idli well a Trinity with shifting eyes
with stare at onlookers so meanwhile
while the church is using these types of
atonement we actually have transatlantic
travel tradition transoceanic travel
growing its significance in the 17th
century
so obviously the importance of reliable
navigation at sea became an issue so
scientists had been working on this
problem for quite some time but in 1714
the Queen Anne act was used to try to
get people to calculate longitude at sea
so latitude was relatively easy but
longitude was not this was solved by
John Harrison who was a clockmaker who
actually created this particular piece
which is H 4 this is the world's first
ship chronometer that allowed us to
calculate longitude at sea reliably and
then about the same time we actually had
the development of the pinned cylinder
this began in the early part of the 18th
century so at this point we were
actually able to start creating automata
that enacted the task that previously
they only appeared to perform this also
led to the first instances of mechanical
organs and Carolyn's
so this is a really interesting piece
because we have this this piece in 1723
clockmaker charles clay begins employing
the pin cylinder in these in his organs
and what's on the right is actually a
document this was an actual piece of
sheet music that was written by a georg
friedrich händel who it's believed wrote
songs ten songs for clays musical clocks
so it's most interesting about these
particular pieces of the fact that this
was the first instance perhaps of
recorded music it allowed a magician to
generate songs that previously were not
capable of the human hands so if you
think about it you only have ten notes
you have ten fingers if you create an
organ that has 28 pipes you have 28
available notes so here we have Handel
creating these beautiful pieces from
mechanical organs
[Music]
[Music]
it's pretty good right okay so about the
same time as that we have all this stuff
kind of developing simultaneously
these were three automata that were
created in the 1730's so this is right
around the same time that that organ
clock was made this is made by Jax de
vaucanson
he was more of a philosopher and a
scientist than anything else but he
became very interested in anatomy after
meeting a surgeon and he created these
three automata that were the first
automata that we know of that actually
could perform acts that previous ones
could only simulate so we had the paipa
store the flutist that was on the left
he had the drummer on the right and the
notorious defecating duck in the center
very interesting yes so the flutist may
have been one of the most complicated of
these three he actually had lips that
flexed in four directions he had lungs
that could play three blowing pressures
he had fully articulated fingers so that
he could actually make contact with the
flutes but what was interesting was that
clemson struggled with how to make the
contact so that it actually the finger
sealed over the aperture of the flute so
he actually covered the fingers and real
skin in order to make the contact it was
said that people ventured from all over
to here and see these pieces play and
you could even bring your own flute for
this flute player so the duck though is
probably the most famous it flapped its
wings and cavorted very duck ashley but
its main attracting was that it could
swallow bits of grain and then excrete
them in a changed form on the other end
this was mostly most likely achieved
with food coloring and maybe bread
crumbs or something but it had over 400
moving parts in each wing alone
unfortunately none of these automata
exist today these were the last the last
of his works actually what forms the
museum desserts métiers in Paris France
I really highly recommend going there
what's quite interesting was that this
mod
this was a later model that was made
this has also been lost but it was
robert-houdin who I will talk about
later that owned this duck and revealed
that it was a fake so not long after
vaucanson gave up on making automata a
Swiss clock maker named Jacques ade Rose
ended up making these three pieces here
so we had the writer the draftsman and
the piano player
jackie-joyce was also responsible for
our first instances of singing birds as
we know them today these three were made
in about the 1770s okay well as you know
this as you just heard he actually was
able to engineer the very Ogden writing
and in doing so we have the very
earliest programmable computer because
this particular piece of all of the
characters of which is already they
could be removed replaced and reordered
in any orientation so it meant that you
could write any sentence up to 40
characters these allowed the writer in
principle to and then at about the same
time we have my very favorite otamatone
in history being made this was produced
in 1773
this is supposed to have sound
[Music]
so this one has three mechanisms it has
a mechanism that produces the effect of
the water where these contra-rotating
twisted glass rods are moving which
actually simulates the reflection of
water itself we have the Caroline of
bells which plays music and we have the
neck which actually extends down and
allows the Swan to gobble up and swallow
up one of his fish so this being made in
1773 was another one of these golden age
beautiful eighteenth-century automata
that went on to inspire later
generations continuing in this vein of
wonder we have robber who done this is
the gentleman who revealed the
defecating duck to be a fake so he did
many things and not only was he an
incredible clock maker and magician and
also invented the mystery clock he
actually was hired by the French
government to put down a rebellion
so his magic was so good they hired him
to go out and pretend to be a sorcerer
and he basically saved France so not
many clock makers can put that on their
CV what's most interesting is the fact
that robert-houdin was the son of a
watchmaker and had planned to be a
watchmaker but actually went to law
school and while he went to a book shop
to collect a two-volume set on law he
was mistakenly given a two-volume set on
magic and the world was never the same
he ended up moving into Paris and
marrying the daughter of a prominent
clock maker and his time there really
rebase achill II totally redid magic
he's considered the father of modern
magic and was the first magician to
incorporate mechanical devices and
clocks using electricity into his shows
which was definitely a result of his
work as a clock maker one of his most
famous tricks is this mechanical orange
tree this tree toured all around Europe
and is quite one of the the most beloved
tricks I think in the Middle Ages Audrey
this is a recreation
maybe
not playing well this is a recreation of
one of his most famous tricks the leaves
which taught Julie there we go okay so
this mechanical tree they actually had
real oranges so this was a an orange
tree that was kind of beautiful left on
my stage and the background this is a
clip from the Paul Daniels magic show
he's displaying the tree here what would
happen is Houdin in the course of his
magic show would take some article or
item from an audience member and then he
would vanish it look quit it would be
lost but as the show went on and this
was all perfectly timed I did a tree it
would begin to bloom tiny white flowers
and then eventually I would start to see
these three oranges that began to appear
around the audience and these were real
oranges so what I would do is he would
take them he would cut them up and he
would actually pass them around as you
know party favors to audience members
during this performance but as the
evening win one very sharp knife there
he's taking from that's Debbie she's
considered a national treasure of
England his assistant but that top
orange would open and as it did you
would begin to see this handkerchief
that was carried by two mechanical
butterflies and attached to this
handkerchief would be the item that had
been vanished during the show so thereby
the victim would get their precious item
back so not only did who then inspire a
lot of firms to actually go on and
develop other mystery clocks but he also
inspired the very famous Russian
goldsmith Peter Carl Faberge so Faberge
was the goldsmith to the Czar Nicholas
the second and took much of his
inspiration for master works of the past
so this is his version of the huden
orange tree this is known as the bay
tree egg this is from 1911 so instead of
having the handkerchief that carries
this piece with the butterflies it
actually has a singing bird in the
center which is also a homage to Jacques
Rose who invented the singing bird
here is none other than his tiny silver
swan otamatone this actually came in
another one of his beautiful eggs
he actually had 52 of these eggs that
were created by Faberge for the tsar
nicholas ii he had a standing order of
two of these every year so there was one
for his mother and one for his wife this
beautiful egg has matte lilac enamel it
has the Swan that sits in a bed of
aquamarine with all these beautiful
little flowers what's probably most
surprising thing about this mechanical
Swan is the fact that it is actually
made of gold and then played it in
silver how's that for an Easter present
and this is from the Year 1906
when Peter Carl took over his father's
firm there was definitely this move from
producing jewelry to producing kind of
artists jeweler type objects so this
particular one was the peacock egg don't
know if I mentioned this but his mother
got all of the mechanical ones so this
was this beautiful peacock that
certainly had to have been influenced by
another older art work since the fabergé
firm was actually also the keepers of
the objects inside the Hermitage they
looked after and repaired many of the
objects within the collection there
this allowed Faberge to go and study all
of these older pieces and build replicas
and different pieces that would pay
homage to these master works of the past
so this is the peacock egg from 1908
it's actually made of rock crystal so
what you're seeing is a beautiful clear
crystal that's what she does and
surprises obviously the speed with which
made a future gold as well that's also
been enameled with these beautiful
colors this required the skill of many
individuals so it wasn't just Faberge
but he employed many different people so
Goldsmith's silversmiths a lapidary and
enamel ists tone setters as well as a
mechanic to engineer the devices but
this is quite the complicated little
object walks along in the table raises
its tail and it spreads its feathers
this is not unlike the peacock clock
that was also designed by James [ __ ] so
the inventor of the Silver Swan
otamatone also created this mechanical
peacock clock this was commissioned by
Catherine the Great and it arrived in
Saint Petersburg in 1781 it took the
mechanics 15 years to reconstruct this
once it arrived at the Hermitage it is
the only large otamatone from this time
that actually remains intact today so if
you see this clock you're really staring
right back into the 18th century it's
virtually unchanged from when it was
installed so we have her ology creating
all these beautiful objects of wonder
and opulence but also being used in
modern science so at the same time the
Faberge is creating his beautiful
peacock egg we have World War one and we
have mechanical devices and detonators
and our explosives that are are you know
obviously being used for war and
destruction so many of these were
manufactured by the Maine watch
companies including Bulova and Timex the
same engineers that were making those
devices are the same ones that were
manufacturing calibrating the devices to
detonate our first examples of
human-made
existential risk so we have that nation
of our first nuclear bombs also being
part of this horological lineage
this is 1945 this image from the
Smithsonian National Air and Space
Museum shows Apollo 11 in 1969 the Omega
Speedmaster
on the left was actually the aviation or
pilots standard right for our astronauts
so this is the watch that every
astronaut we're at war when they went to
the moon it was later instrumental I
believe in Apollo 16 maybe there was 14
seconds that this watch was used to save
the mission and what's interesting is
also during Apollo 11 we had the
electronic timer onboard malfunction
during the landing and what was used to
save them but this very simple
mechanical timer that worked in 6 minute
and 6 second intervals horological
mechanisms that were once used to
detonate our bombs are actually now what
are being used in our nuclear fail-safes
so this is a small watch sized
mechanical device
was produced in 2011 and is now the
larger safety initiative that's
basically a part of our safety protocol
so this little mechanical safe arming
detonator is an extremely intricate
nuclear safety component that actually
prevents accidental detonation of our
nuclear bombs and moving on we actually
have right now since 2015 the Jet
Propulsion Laboratory has started to
develop a clockwork Rover for Venus so
this Rover is all mechanical and is
based off of Charles Babbage adding
machine as well as the Antikythera
mechanism this was conceived by an
engineer named Jonathan solder he's a
mechatronics engineer at the Jet
Propulsion Laboratory and the idea is
the fact that basically electronics will
not work on the Venus surface obviously
the temperatures are really too extreme
for any type of electronic device to
function so what has to be done is to
try to solve this problem mechanically
so we have this age-old technology
solving rocket science problems so why
is all of this important and what is my
role in all of this right so you've got
this timeline that kind of demonstrates
how a lot of these objects have been
used for some of our most beautiful and
some of our most terrifying pursuits
within I think our our endeavors as
human beings and so my role within that
is that I like to think of myself as a
you know if I only could think of myself
as Rob Eyre who did this is a clip from
when I went to the magic Museum in Paris
so very excitedly revealed myself as who
done my job as a conservator and a her
ologist is actually to preserve all
these things right so these tiny objects
are so delicate these little pieces are
about the size of my pinky this tiny
bird has maybe over 30 pieces in it
alone and this little bird is part of a
singing bird mechanism so when I go in
to work on something like this I am my
first priority is actually making sure
that the object stays is true to
historic its historic values or its
properties as possible so for example if
there is a thread in this piece that
stripped I will not put a new modern
thread or a new modern screw in there I
will actually get a screw plate from the
era from which this piece was made and
remake the screw using historically
accurate threads because this was made
before screws were standardized so here
is this tiny little mechanism there's
our little protagonist or singing bird
and each of these pieces are really
different that one I call a panic attack
he's very quick they all have these
really specific personalities so
basically each one though though many of
them were produced in a series and
produced by the same firm none of them
were really the same the parts are not
interchangeable so you can't have one
and change things from one to the other
and even the song and the way that it's
feathered and the way that it behaves is
really a reflection of the craftsman
that engineered it and made it made it
by hand this is another one my favorite
so inside you actually see a video
that's a little bit larger which will
explain it all to you but basically it's
a bellows and a slide whistle with a
plunger that goes in at a depth that's
programmed it's predetermined by a cam
so we were actually pretty obsessed with
reanimating dead things so not only were
using skin on flute fingers but we were
taking real birds that were taxing our
meat and then stuffing them with
clockwork so what's interesting about
this is that we have this beautiful
scarlet tanager that is you know still
alive long after all of its family and
counterparts have moved on this is a
piece that I actually did here I made
this bird from scratch it's not a
stuffed bird individual feathers have
been applied so there you can see the
bellows they're pumping they're on the
left and then you have the slide whistle
and you can see there's a plunger that's
moving in and out at a rapid pace this
is all dictated by these toothed wheels
which are called cams and basically the
cams are telling that that plunger how
far to go inside the whistle bore and
then at the same time you have a release
of a valve and that's causing the trill
of the bird so that's where you're
getting the and then you get there like
that this is an interesting piece that I
worked on for the National Trust this
was an angle see in the angle see a bee
National Trust House in the United
Kingdom this actually was from the
Forbidden City museum there in Beijing
this had been owned by one of the
Emperor's and what's really interesting
about this piece and what's interesting
about all of these pieces and these
examples that I'm showing it was
that each one is quite different and the
ethical considerations that we give to
each piece are quite considered so this
is an interesting example of a fusion
between basically Chinese engineering
and English engineering so we had this
original mechanism being made in London
and it was also made by James Kok so the
gentlemen that created that Stirling
Swan as well as that peacock clock made
this clock now this has two mechanisms
it has a simple clock mechanism that's
used for telling the time and then it
has a more complicated otamatone
mechanism with bells and such for
playing music and governing the movement
of the different figures on this clock
so what happened was when it went to I
went to Beijing when it went to the
Forbidden City the Emperor decided that
it didn't play fast enough he didn't
want the western music so what he had
his clock makers do was to actually
remove the original Springs and put much
larger springs in this made it run much
faster so we ended up having something
that didn't quite sound like it did when
it left here
and probably what's most fascinating
about that particular pieces journey is
the fact that the people at Anglesey
abbey that had visited and seen this
clock play got so used to hearing it and
seeing it play in this modified state
that when it came time to do the
restoration they decided they wanted it
left as it was so the National Trust
decided to leave it in an altered state
which actually long-term was detrimental
for the movement so we had to do some
creative problem-solving with that this
was a tiny otamatone ship that I worked
on this was made in 1810 it was made as
a Battle of Trafalgar Memorial so this
little piece when it came to me was
actually silent and it has a musical
component it also was not working and
there was nothing to really tell me what
type of object this was when it was made
or how it should look so there was a lot
of kind of research and things done to
figure that out I ended up deciding that
it should have a case for the pocket so
I made this case out of sterling silver
this is made out of sterling silver
sheet that was formed and then soldered
together and in order to rectify the
problems within the mechanism to get it
to play again I made this little barrel
to test the different sizes and shapes
and angles of pins that would normally
cause the steel comb to resonate so like
that music box that we saw in the first
slide and how the pins would actually
pluck those resonating steel tines this
should have done the same thing but when
the tines were contacting the comb
nothing was produced no sound it was
silent so I made this little barrel and
use different sized and shaped pens and
eventually discovered that the Pens had
worn down and they had originally been
shaped at a very particular angle in
order to be producing the sound so once
that and a bunch of other stuff was
resolved I was able to get the piece
working and here it is in its little box
it's very quiet
the 400 hours worth it all just for that
that's I guess that's my point these
things are so time-consuming and they
require the utmost attention to detail
if we want to treat them right
and we want to honor their history and
our heritage another difficult problem
this was a smoking otamatone so imagine
you know you're alive in 1870 you're an
older gentleman you retired you're
smoking lounge with your scotch in the
evening and you know your wife isn't
interested in having a cigarette with
you that's fine you've got this guy so
you would take your otamatone you'd wind
them up you'd put a cigarette in you'd
light his cigarette you'd blade yours
and the two of you would smoke together
and if you know much about smoking um
you know that that's probably not the
best for your health long-term automata
actually suffer the same fate
so for me my my job here was to figure
out okay well what can I do to prolong
the life of this otamatone because this
is made of pretty delicate materials we
have paper mache we have textiles we
have these organic materials that
decorate naturally over time right so
basically entering intervention to this
object would cause damage to these
materials which become more and more
fragile everyday so over a lot of time
in research you can see I basically
rectified a lot of the aesthetic
problems but in order to rectify the
problems with the bellows system which
are the most vulnerable material within
this because it has the direct exposure
to smoke
I built this machine this machine was
made to smoke three cigarettes at once
so each of these bellows is covered in a
different material and exposed to
cigarette smoke at the same time and
basically after cigarette exposure I
then tested to see which material would
last the longest by testing it to
destruction so basically looking at the
chemical structure its chemical bonds so
here's the machine
I smelt like a casino after this no one
wanted to be around me
so everything about this was calibrated
so that it would run at the rate that
the otamatone ran and would produce a
good puff so you know I wanted to get a
material that was really going to give
you a lot of bang you know for your puff
and once I figured out which material
was going to be the best here he is
doing what he does best so here he's
been finished with this hat and hair and
a very fine miss - what's the gentleman
without his monocle
so I also work on silly things like this
this is a bubble blowing bear that I
nicknamed de Beauford here is you know
here you here you watch me now as I blow
these bubbles and this is just a
clockwork mechanism with the bellows
inside again so instead of smoking
cigarettes there he is blowing bubbles
but sometimes you know solving these
problems and getting so excited about
the work this is the first time he was
working after getting him going which
there was supposed to be sound for that
one I don't know if I should replay that
just for the factory
I do love my job for moments like that
but these things were made to light
people and make them happy um what I
love so much about them is that there
was no other motive this is a magician
otamatone so this guy did a very simple
trick he basically just vanished a
little rat and turned it into a cat
which unfortunately I don't have a
picture of actually what that looked
like but this is to kind of get you back
into this idea of using mechanics for
magic this is a magicians pocket watch
that I worked on so I can't tell you how
it worked
magicians cared I would have to kill you
but basically what happened was that the
magician could you know read out the
time from the stage and he would say you
know currently in the watches you know
1247 and he would hand it out to an
audience member and he'd say you know
close the watch don't look at the time I
don't want anyone to see what time it is
now turn the crown and set the watch to
any time so you know the person they'd
get there and they'd turn the crown
you'd say okay once you're satisfied you
know open the watch push the button and
tell me or don't tell me what time it is
I will tell you so then he says you know
I'm divining that it's 3:17 and the
person would verify why yes it's 3:17
he'd say okay now ring the gongs
so this little watch actually is a
repeater so it has a lever on the side
that allowed the person in the audience
to pull it and when he would do that it
would actually ring out the time to the
minute thereby proving that the magician
could divine what time it was this is
another one of my favorites I did not
work on this but what I wanted to share
about this one is the fact that this
little box has questions that you would
actually put in little tokens in the
side right and when you would ask the
question the magician would consult his
books you know and look around and
actually reveal the answer and what I
think is most interesting is the fact
that today these questions are still
very very relevant so what's the most
fleeting thing in life love what is
something that people trust in
universally money and what offers the
greatest consolation but time
as everything passes with time this is
John gone so John gone is what many
people call the magicians magician he
has worked in magic since he was quite
young producing magical illusions for
people magicians and he has a workshop
in LA I went to visit him because he has
an incredible collection this is
Philippe he is a magical peacock that
can pull an ace from a deck of cards I
don't know how he works but if only
someday I could get my hands on Philippe
it's a very short clip but you can see
he's very elegant and his movement
another one of my mentors is Philip Peck
so these are people that today are
really my inspiration these are the
people that I hold up as the best and my
mentors and the type of work that I do
because even with all the time that I
had in school
I'm certainly not I'm still learning
every day
you know I've spent over 10 years in
school and then worked independently and
I still don't know everything and I
don't think I ever will so without
people like this I certainly wouldn't
get as far as I am now this is Philip
Peck he's a master goldsmith and her
ologist he lives in Pennsylvania this is
a beautiful loop that he made called the
collectors loop it has a watch mechanism
on the top with a Geass a dial and we
worked together he helped me create this
original artwork this is a piece that I
made in 2018 which is a part of series
based on medieval bestiary manuscripts
so this is kind of a mash-up of all of
our you know strange thoughts and
desires and our history and philosophy
so this little piece is basically a
homage to this history that I described
quite briefly earlier but here he is
moving
so I created him as kind of a homage to
the lineage of her ology in the same
fashion you know that we have Faberge
creating things I'm certainly not Fabri
shape but this idea that you want to pay
homage to these greater folks and the
lineage of your of your trade or your
craft so this little snail is a is
basically a homage to the disc
combination of nature and the machine so
we have early philosophers like
Descartes saying I know no difference
between the bodies that nature makes on
its own and those that the craftsman
makes so here we have a mechanical snail
who has a shell which is a perfect
mathematical ratio found in nature so it
kind of is this idea that you know God
is a mechanic as well as oh oh you know
ornamental Turner and a mathematician
he kind of just wanders around pops his
head out and he was in a figure 8
pattern this is another one of my
mentors this is Ephraim Shar Gretzky he
is what I would call a master bird
mechanic he is a really incredible
person he spent over ten years trying to
build the most complicated thing in
horological history without having any
prior experience and he's doing it this
is actually original piece from the
paddock fleet museum where perhaps this
was an auction actually at Christie's
but there is a pair of these and them in
the paddock fleet Museum made by
brochette there are over 1000 pieces in
this pistol alone and it's basically
controlled by six mechanisms that act
together to produce the effect of the
bird popping out of the pistol so it's
everything we saw in that bird box
basically lay it out linearly this is
David Lindo he is a clock maker in
Pennsylvania as well so three of these
geniuses all together in Pennsylvania
must be something in the water but David
is building rows engines so rows engines
are basically these incredible machines
that use mathematical principles and
sine waves to generate geometric
patterns in three dimensional or on
metal so this is the maid lathe the maid
lathe is an incredible example of this
because it is the only machine of this
type that can actually perform all of
the functions that the machines of the
past can and it in one so it does fix
tool turning live tool turning and Gyo
Shea which I haven't really explained
all of those things are so hopefully
maybe someone will ask me al Collins one
of the principal designers of the maid
lathe who worked with David Lindo is
generating these crazy barrels using
basically whatever found materials he
can to try to recreate a lot of these
shapes that we find in old ornamental
turnings of the past that we don't know
how they made them so here is one of his
test pieces using one of those barrels
I'll and I also did this coloring book
so this is a coloring book of 80
engine turned patterns as a way to try
to get this information to the public
that wouldn't normally have an
engagement with these patterns this is
one of them is drawn by the chalk robot
I feel you know ornamental turning is
one of these critically endangered
crafts but it also has a relationship to
magic
these are ornament Lee turned vanishing
ball cup tricks here this is also in the
collection of John gone and here on the
Left we have an ornamental II turned
piece that was actually laser-cut and on
the right and original that was made by
a king took a king twelve to eighteen
months to make one of these pieces alone
he imagine a king sitting in a room with
candlelight you know using a foot pedal
or a hand wheel to create this and now
we can print one or cut one in five
minutes so give Shea is kind of the
ancestor of that right so this is this
geometric engraving on metal using sine
waves using the mathematics I teach
classes in this so what's pretty
interesting about this is the fact that
Tristan Duke here is a light refraction
scientist he's actually a holography
said he studies scratch abrasive
holography and there he is talking to
David Lindo I wanted to introduce them
to find out if they could produce
basically a mechanical apparatus for
Rose Engine that would allow the user to
create a hologram a scratch abrasive
hologram on the machine so you can see
this is one of Tristram's test pieces
this is a piece off of my machine here's
another piece off of my machine and
another one of Tristram's pieces so when
you shine a light above this you
actually get a three-dimensional shape
that rises above it each line is
actually producing a point of light that
creates some image and here's Tristan
studying the light off of one of our
Collins boxes and here's one of his
Holograms here's another one with all
Colin's boxes
here's Tristram's test pieces
okay and I'm out of time now so I'm
going to end with this really whimsical
note here that Tristram who believes
again scratch braces holography is the
ancestor of gia Shea which is the
ancestor of ornamental turning of Kings
which is the ancestor of mathematics in
Greece Wow he used it to create this
Millennium Falcon hologram right so
actually if you go out and buy the Star
Wars LP you can have a tiny Millennium
Falcon rise above your of record as you
put it on a record table okay crash
course in virology thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you that was
love and I think the what is especially
great to hear is not only in kind of
your trajectory in this but also seeing
some of your mentors and I mean as you
see from your mentors and what I learned
when I started doing clocks like ten
thousand year clock is the first clock
that I ever worked on and the but the
field is basically a bunch of old guys
retired you know semi engineers or
self-taught engineers and it's so
refreshing to see people kind of getting
into it for a new reasons and so it's it
was really great to read the original
article about you on this and to meet
you today we went to the museum
Echenique my friend Dan szalinski space
if you guys have never been there we
just got a chance to spend about 30-40
minutes down there but it's down at
Fisherman's Wharf which I know no
self-respecting San Franciscan ever goes
to Fisherman's Wharf but you should go
to the museum Echenique and get a big
handful of quarters and I'm just
wondering what were your impressions of
seeing these kind of automata in in read
ready use with just quarters and a bunch
of random people well I mean I think
that's what they were meant to be used
for you know it's it's definitely you
need a balance between just treating
these as historic artifacts that aren't
meant to be used and then actually
engaging with them because this is what
makes people care about them so it was
really fun I was really excited to see
them all working and see people you know
getting excited and putting in more
quarters and playing those old teens ya
know there's and I asked a question I've
always wanted to know the answer to is
how they made the little those barrels
that play the music that have all the
pins in them and you gave me about a
five minute answer that I was not
expecting and it was it was pretty
impressive there's very probably very
few people like
have asked that question two in the
world that would have actually known the
details of that process so it was it was
really cool and I wanted to get a little
bit more about how you how you found
this and why it spoke to you why you
wanted to do this well as a kid I
collected music boxes and kind of any
objects that followed rules so I liked
Springs and magnets and compasses and
mirrors but I really have to blame it on
my maternal great-grandmother because
she gave my me before I was born at my
baby shower a music box and so I grew up
with that and eventually I think my
other my not great-grandmother but her
daughter realized how much I loved that
and because she goes to post-holiday
inventory sales she would always buy me
these kitschy holiday music boxes and I
ended up discarding the top of them and
just keeping the mechanism and so for me
you know I never told my grandmother
that hopefully my grandma never sees
this but I loved the I loved the music
and I loved the rules that made the
thing work and basically I just thought
that those things made a lot more sense
than a lot of other stuff in the world
at that time and so I was very drawn to
them and ended up going into school for
philosophy and at the same time was
working as a jeweler and I studied
metaphysics epistemology in school and
ended up learning about the automata
that were made as kind of these
apparatuses to study philosophical
problems in the past and I was
fascinated by that so kind of went down
a rabbit hole and just kept going so you
quit being a philosopher well at least a
formal philosopher and then started
going to clockmaking school yes I had
gotten accepted to a dual PhD master's
program and kind of just bailed and pack
what would fit in my car and drove to
Seattle and the role wouldn't watch me
in school and I mean are there other
people that I mean I showed some of the
some of your mentors but what is your
kind of day-to-day and what is the who's
your competition in the world like so
somebody has a broken automata and
they're their list of people to send
this to is probably fairly short either
as a museum conservator which is within
a museum which I assume aren't really
out for public hire or it's you are
there others and is there an ecosystem
of this yeah I mean there's definitely
some talented people in Europe there's I
would say you know the the workshop that
I worked in at Museum spill clock in the
Netherlands would be as they actually do
outside work so I'm just advertising for
them now if you if you would like to
send an object to them you can contact
Martyn Paris and is that what happens
for the most part somebody has a thing I
mean you showed a few of these things
that are someone maybe gets them in Oxon
or finds them in their grandparents
attic and then they don't make it go I
mean it just depends a lot of times my
clients are you know it's a family
person they've got the one thing that's
very valuable to them and they just want
to see it working and see it treated
properly so then they find me or someone
like me and otherwise mostly its
collectors you have several things and
they just want the thing to work and
then they want to put it back in their
vaults um you know or it's or it's a
museum that has something special that's
gonna go on display I was especially
intrigued by the testing machine you
built for the smoking machine with when
we're working on the the clock for loan
now one of the most difficult things to
do is to understand how long it's going
to like will it operate for the number
of cycles in our case you know it's if
it if it's a thing that operates once a
day that's three point six five million
cycles that we want to test it for but
we also don't want to accelerate the
testing too fast because then it it's
not realistic to the heat that might
generate and things like that do you it
was that the first thing like that that
you built or do you build other testing
apparatus to figure these things out I
mean that was the first thing that was
that complicated so yeah I mean
certainly you make like for example that
test barrel in that ship that was
literally just to test the shapes of
pens and that actually went right into
the mechanism so it wasn't something
that was a separate apparatus but
unfortunately I don't have enough time
and finances to build a smoking
apparatus or something of the like for
every machine that I get so yeah I would
love to but right yeah and I was
intrigued by as I mean when we went over
this beforehand and as well as tonight
that a lot of automata kind of has this
history of secret magic that's a kind of
this deception as well as some actual
deceptions that were like that that the
not pooping duck or the you know the
Mechanical Turk is the other famous
example of the automata that didn't work
that was a fake and I'm curious to where
do you think this comes from in our in
our history of what do we want the
mechanical things to fool us I think
there's something really nice about
being fooled you know I think on my
deathbed I just hope there's a magician
and you continue to work with magicians
oh yeah making things for magicians or
fixing magic tricks is really fun you
know some I think there's something so
special about the fact that it's all
self-contained you know there's not this
hidden element of electricity or
pre-program I mean certainly there are
pre programs but it's all mechanical
it's all handmade and there's something
kind of magical just about that cool and
I also had one a very specific question
before we get to audience questions and
that is do you know what why the Apollo
timer was 6 minutes and 6 seconds what
was the significance of that you know I
wish I did know that I've wondered that
myself no and I don't know if you saw
the Apollo 11 documentary which was
excellent if you didn't see it highly
recommend it but they didn't even
mention it
where's horology folks actually Creon
who worked at NASA for a long time and
turned me on to the book digital Apollo
I know I bet you it's covered in that
book and I'm not remembering some of my
favorite yeah all right so yeah there's
a great book called Digital Apollo which
was also shows you that all this amazing
history of how a human computer
interface was kind of first discovered
in the Apollo era that we still we still
go by today
of that stuff so no better has that
answer to itself I'll look it up and
post it but I think this I mean the the
crossover to to the defense industry and
that you know that's these fail-safes
for systems that even now my
understanding is that even now the
nuclear arsenal is air gapped and you
can electronic gapped by kind of
mechanical maze systems so that they
can't be gamed by electronic means is an
interesting last holdout for for the
mechanical world of computers in a way I
don't think it can be replaced yeah does
anybody else have any questions
Creon yeah I wondered if you have
investigated or have any thoughts on
things like Pascal and Konrad Zuse and
Charles Babbage and sir the whole
connection between these mechanical
automata if you will and the world of
computing which a lot of people are here
in because they're again they did as
with physics and and ocean transport
these mechanical devices kind of lie at
the foundation of modern computing what
exactly was your question just my father
relations of sorry just for the non live
audience relation of computing and
clockmaking to our current history of
computing right current state of
computing right the first computers were
all mechanical well I think that's why I
used the example of the rover right so
the fact that we are actually relying on
these early mechanical computing systems
to solve rocket you know space problems
today because we don't have another way
to solve them you know they're actually
building a Venus chamber with which to
put a mechanical device and because it
won't operate on Earth conditions so
they actually have to build something
and tested and this other space to see
if it works I think that you know we're
gonna end up using these types of
mechanisms because they can't be
replaced it's something that can't
really be it's a stopgap between
electronics and satellites and
artificial intelligence you know it's
this last all tactile holdout that we
craft individually each component and
this is also a reason why we we made the
10000 year clock mechanical it's if you
you know if you found an electronic
clock that's not working hasn't been
working for a thousand years it's very
difficult to reverse engineer it we're
kind of these objects that you find you
have some chance of reverse engineering
that understanding at least the majority
of how they worked if you have a
question actually we have a mic going
around yep I have two similar related
questions you could do both or either
does null gravity affect how mechanical
watches operate like did Neil
Armstrong's watch perform differently in
space well I think they did a lot of
test flights with these to see how they
would actually operate in space and I
mean they were very reliable but I do
know that when NASA and later missions
they had some detonation tests on the
moon there was a problem with the
mechanical apparatus like the balance
over banking so they ended up Charles
solder who was in
near ended up basically adjusting the
escapement so that you wouldn't have
ever banking on the lunar surface
anymore and how do very old clocks like
the one in Prague that lived through
World Wars survived well I think it
didn't really so the oldest people like
you yeah but a lot of its new so I think
it was badly damaged and then it parts
were rebuilt in the 1600s but I think
the oldest part is you know from 1410
but very little little little of it it's
from that that period so it's just been
you know rebuilt and added on over time
yeah that clock that you showed that
salisbury cathedral tower clock it's on
the the mezzanine above where the first
prototype of our clock is in the making
of the modern world thing in every hour
when we're installing it you eat they
would you eat it it was an hour maybe
was at noon they would run it but it's
amazing they were still running this you
know clock that was so old but they had
a whole machine shop of people
downstairs that were also maintaining
various wear surfaces and keeping it
going that's great
[Laughter]
yeah I was hoping you could explain the
function of a turning and what this
beautiful design on the chalkboard is
and how that plays out in the mechanisms
that you're talking about okay well
that's a long story but yes okay so this
is called ornamental turning our engine
turning which basically these shapes are
generated through sine waves did you
need to ask that question or can I just
okay so basically the the sine wave or
the wave form is is phased or varied and
the way that you phase are very the wave
formed will shift the orientation of the
pattern or the wave so if you think
about a sine wave and you phase that by
180 degrees you get the the mirror
opposite so you get these 2 lines
dancing together if you face it
gradually a little bit in one direction
and then you go back and then you go
back and then you go back you get this
pattern so this is kind of a little
zigzag pattern but each line
as it's you know shown here is the same
waveform repeated so it's not changed
it's just moved a little bit and this
was basically the ancestor to ornamental
turning which was the practice of kings
and sovereigns to commune with God in a
way so the idea was that if the world
was created based on harmonic and
mathematical principles this was
evidence that God was in nature through
mathematical perfect ratios so like the
Fibonacci sequence or the nautilus shell
so these were observable mathematical
principles in nature which could then be
translated to turning on a machine
through these sine waves and phasing the
wave the rave forms and if done properly
you would get these beautiful ivory
towers that the Kings would build so
over time basically it changed from a
tool of Kings to commune with God to
tools of craftsmen to make things for
kings to something that went obsolete
basically after world war ii now you can
imagine our president spending that much
time he'd be a better a better president
I'm sure so I'm in love with your little
snail rabbit and when we were talking
earlier you said that you had 12 that
you wanted to build from the bestiary 's
and i wondering which do you most want
to build and why so there's I would love
to do 12 but I feel like 10 is pushing
his person my time constraints but
probably the one I really want to do
next is the stag otamatone so I started
this piece this is a very strange mashup
of a stag right so when they would see
the stag in the forest they actually
imagined that it had wings and had this
crucifix suspended between its antlers
so why do I want to make that one next I
guess because it's um I'm gonna feather
it it'll have lots of beautiful feathers
so I'm really looking forward to
actually the process of making this
piece but it was the first one that I
wanted to make I think because I thought
that it was really the most elegant of
all of the ones inside the bestiary
because a lot of the other ones are
really weird
with these projects do you take
commissions or do these are the things
you do on your own time well I would
take commissions but this particular
series is just something that I have
thought you know these are really
interesting examples of human
vulnerability and projection of our own
feelings on the natural world and
they've never really been animated so
how interesting would it be to actually
animate these strange things when a lot
of our compulsion behind animating
things was also a projection of our
vulnerabilities about you know not
wanting to basically have something that
would live on after us right so get over
our own mortality yep like can you speak
a little bit about whether you use
contemporary tools at least in your own
practice you use CAD or you'll mostly
pencil catting it how did how do you
create you know how do you move into
that space and what does it look like
compared to being a conservator and the
tools you're allowed there well I think
for me I've been criticized for being
too traditional there are I think things
about my practice and what I feel one of
the most valuable parts of this is the
fact that not only are these objects
valuable but the skills needed to
preserve them are so if anything the
skills are more critically endangered
than the objects at this point so as
long as I continue to practice those
skills I'm still preserving my my art
form if I move over to rely on something
like CNC I have to stop and wonder if
I'm actually the one making the object
or if the machine is making the object
at a certain point I think you know
you're assisting the Machine instead of
having the machine assist you so you can
draw all your things I do badly I
wouldn't say that I'm great at draftsman
but yes I strawberry but yeah where's
our where's the mic
so I have a question when you are we
federal those berths do you use like
synthetic fetter or do you actually go
out and buy get real fetter and then the
color of it things like that like can
you tell a little bit more details of
that yeah so for the feathers you know
obviously these are real bird feathers
and when these things were made they
were made to feather like little jewels
or gemstones they actually wanted to
have this glittering effect so these
were feathered using real hummingbird
feathers obviously that's not something
I can just go out and get and run out
there with the net catching hummingbirds
but you know if I if I have to reefer I
generally try to preserve as many of the
original feathers as possible and use
feathers that are going to be
historically accurate where I can so if
I'm able to secure some you know
Victorian taxidermy feathers in that
case I would you know use some of those
to supplement the original if it's a
later bird and dyed feathers are used
then I would use feathers that were dyed
it just depends on what era right we're
gonna wrap up with the last couple
questions yeah um
you touched briefly on the Antikythera
mechanism I was a sort of a two-part
question could you speak a little more
about it and a three-part question
has anybody figured out what it does and
the third part of the question how would
you figure out what it does it was
underwater for a long time it looks like
it's kind of rusted into one piece
that's all very true I think they
x-rayed it so they were able to kind of
figure out from the x-rays what was
there what should have been there so
that gave us kind of a basis for what
that mechanism looked like but as far as
what it does it's a it's basically an
animal those of you don't know this was
a mechanism it was 2,000 years old found
at the bottom of the of the
Mediterranean and is set back what we
now know as modern kind of clockwork and
neurology and astronomical machines but
it was very rusted and oxidized and so
it was
that took a very long time to figure out
I think for the longest time it just sat
basically in a box and they were like oh
whatever
and somebody was like wait a minute this
thing is important but it's a it's an
analog calculator I think it's a
calendar actually an astronomical
calendar and basically they created a
replica of it they have that I believe
at the Smithsonian so you can actually
go see it but you know this was not a
super well made object but I what I
think if anything that's evidence for
the fact that we actually had a lot of
these automata and calculators and
machines that we hear about in
manuscripts so the Antikythera mechanism
is actually proof that we were making
complicated machines you know in the
time of the Greeks so we have a lot of
evidence of these really interesting
pieces that were part of the pleasure
gardens and palaces of the Greeks with
moving figures and automata pneumatics
hydraulics and this proves that these
things were actually being made well I
was I was especially took a lot of heart
when I found out that that peacock
automata I took 15 years because that's
about how long I'm into making the
current clock project so I wanted to
thank you and give you a long nail
challenge coin and please give her a
round of applause
[Applause]
[Music]